series is a sum you're adding up the
terms in a sequence okay and together
that makes a series okay it's the sum of
all those terms finite just means it's a
fixed number of terms as opposed to
infinite right going on forever and ever
so you might just be finding the sum of
the first 10 terms 20 terms 30 terms
like that so the form that we're gonna
be using here is a sub n so the sum of
the first n terms equals a sub 1 which
is the first term times 1 minus the
ratio that's what you're multiplying by
to get to the next term raised to the
nth power which is that what however
many terms you have is 20 and I'll be 20
all divided by 1 minus R now when you're
using this formula you want to make sure
you follow the PEMDAS you know the order
of operations you want to do the R to
the end first and then take 1 minus that
you don't want to do 1 minus R and then
raise it to the end you'll get a
different answer so make sure you follow
the order of operations and you'll get
it let's look at this first example here
now we talked about how to work with
this Sigma notation before in a previous
video when we talked about arithmetic
series but basically what you do is you
start with this bottom index which I
equals 1 and you work your way up 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 okay and you put in 1 for I
2 for I 3 for I all the way up to 10 the
e the Sigma just means that you're
summing up all those terms so what I
like to do is I like to write a few of
the terms down just to get a feel for
the what's going on so if I put 1 in 1
minus 1 is 0 2 to the 0 is 1 times 3 is
3 if we put 2 in we get 2 minus 1 is 1 2
to the first is 2 times 3 is 6 if we put
3 in 3 minus 1 is 2 2 squared is 4 times
3 is 12 plus dot dot dot so what you can
see here is that we're multiplying by 2
each time see their base is 2 and the
first term is 3 so we can see that
that's the first term
and so our ratio is 2 we're multiplying
by 2 okay but what we want to do is want
to find the sum of the the first 10
terms so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna use our formula we've got s sub 10
equals the first term a sub 1 which is 3
1 minus the ratio which is what we're
multiplying by to get to the next term
if you're not sure how to find the ratio
just take
the term and / the one before it so 12
divided by 6 is 2 6 divided by 3 is 2
that's how you can find the ratio so
that's going to be 2 to the 10th power
because we're finding the sum of the
first 10 terms these ends are the same
okay all divided by 1 minus the ratio
which is 2 okay so let's see if we can
simplify here so this is going to be 3 1
minus 2 to the 10th I'm going to do that
in that calculator 1 minus 2 is negative
1 so 2 to the 10th is how much well
let's see here we got 2 to the 10th
power thousand 24 okay 1 minus 1024 is a
negative 1,000 23 divided by negative 1
makes it a positive
1023 if we multiply those together we
get 3 0 6 9 okay so that's the sum of
the first 10 terms ok the next example
we're gonna look at here they've written
out the series for us okay and you can
see the first term is 6 it looks like
they're multiplying by 2 again to get
the next term and they want us to find
the sum of the first 20 terms okay so
they made a little bit easier on us on
this one I'm at the same idea we're use
this formula its S sub 20 okay equals
the first term which is 6 times 1 minus
the ratio which is 2 to the 20th power
all divided by 1 minus the ratio which
is 2 and you just have to again use the
order of operations to simplify that and
you'll get the sum so I hope you're
enjoying these videos if you are go
ahead and subscribe check out some of my
other videos I'm going to be showing you
in the next video how to find the sum of
an infinite geometric series so go ahead
and check that one out and I'll see you
in the next video